avec nous serge beaulieu le président
des producteurs et productrices
acéricoles du québec consomme ce nouveau
lieu
est ce que vous saviez tout cela à
propos de ma cabane à la maison
je vous y reste des choses qu'on a envie
de programmer cet été où ce qui amène
les organisations que la prochaine où il
ya mahdi professeur qui tape aux
recettes ce fait la façon que ça se
faisait sécher qu'un autre
peuple si ça celikkol honoraires pour ce
regroupement alors s'ils se font sans
les exploits stocks se sont regroupés
pour avoir un modèle d'affaires qui les
ont
le plus concret séguin avait 150 et
250 cabanes à sucre commercial
avec différents modèles d'affaires mais
ce que vous conseillez vos membres de
vous dissocier de cette marque là
où je vous dirais d'assaut on ne sait
point et piqué sont les causé
d'annulations s'est pas impliqué pour la
formatio doute la seule chose que des
organisations avec ses canaux à no
comments et il a posé
ma cabane à la maison cette année on est
revenue à pékin
nouveau concept n'est pas nouveau et on
aimerait aussi un site internet de
toutes vos prospects qui va l'amener à
la cabane où ce qu'on a
[Musique]
écrit aussi des cabanes à ce jeu là on
voyait des places 27e
érable d'ici qui est gérée par les
concerts précieuse acéricoles qui
regroupe des les six arbres ceux qui
vendent sur de l'herbe à la ferme
chez nous ok en avant le dernier vous
avez libéré la moitié de la réserve
stratégique de sirop du québec on
parlait de pénurie mondiale de sirop je
vous pose la question tout de go
monsieur beaulieu est ce qu'on est en
train de manquer de sirop
c'est ce que se reconnaît mme c aux
moyennes comme on dit là bas aussi parce
que cette saison c'était une saison
moyenne
la pression est forte parce que tu es là
pour aller au tome c'était la moitié des
réserves
quand on va commencer la saison du jeu
c'est environ 35 millions niveau qui
reste à poser car on a commencé c'est à
105 millions de livres il y avait
entreposé pour 6 allez une petite année
il faut se rappeler que on a eu des
ventes d augmentation devrait pour sa
part année dans les deux dames hier si
jamais vu ouais c'est qu'avec sauf que
c'est pour ça que cet été at on vu la
réaction aux consommateurs comme
pénalement on a alloué cinq millions
d'enfants une nouvelle on ne dira août
ressort vous devriez si vous avez
déclaré nathan tauriel mais à 7 millions
de nouvelles actions ont été allouées
qui vont être mis en production de ces
un parti cette année petit la prochaine
c'est combien ça de sirop 7 millions
dans taille de plus
grosso modo cbc millions de livres de
sirop supplémentaires auxquelles le
savez millions de livres supplémentaires
mais vous combler regardez la réserve
quand tu vas arriver une pub cette année
qu'on soit capable de ressortir ses
revenus pendant la dernière harry y
opposent une augmentation si le prix
auprès de spare parts justement parce
qu'avant de réserve pour fournir les
notre informateur qui bande de se serrer
les coudes allemand et là vous avez eu
quand même beaucoup d'intérêt la avec
l' annonce 7 millions d'entaillés 4000
demandes si je me trompe pas et 1300
assir acériculteurs de plus cette année
une nouvelle façon de faire pourrait
loin que nos transports s'inscrivait à
piles on y aller au combat tôt à partie
de nos mardeuil qu'on avait décidé dès
demain avec cette année ses 1300
nouveaux gloucester qui vont arriver à
la production cette année où la
brasserie et 6300 poster leur se sont
séparés pour au point 3 millions la rai
l'autre point c'est mignon au été sur
les à grasse mais on avait aussi un
projet aussi que l'épreuve soit vouloir
élever la pièce il m'a dit les appareils
de disponible du pouvoir
servir aux
55 ans
a versé 1300 poster des jeux et 6 2
[Musique]
ok et là c'est le début aujourd'hui de
votre tournée régionale et de votre
dernière tournée régionale vous allez
quitter bientôt la présidence monsieur
beaulieu
a annoncé la
nasa annuel cette année sylvain sacs de
riz
à drummondville est là pour si j'avais
annoncé que cet amour dernier monde sait
que oui je vois ma derniers tours
meilleur
dans la roue libre store j'allais me
sentir à contrer cette année 1
[Musique]
ont fait tomber ben ali est
habituellement rencontre mais si c'est
nécessaire proust un sou lycée mais le
toit à 8 en main ou tirer c'était une
excellente occasion de connaître le
poulbot brewster de faire la
transparence et des heures de débat d
idées pour seulement faire évoluer notre
chiot il ne pression qui vous dirait on
est des livres mondiale
mais là vous allez faire sa part zoom et
puis vous vous reprendrez quand vous
aurez quitté vous aurez peut-être plus
de temps monsieur beaulieu merci d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit